so if you wait till your 30s your odds
of having fertility problems go up your
odds of having a child with
complications or um you know birth
defects goes up so that makes raising
kids more expensive as well so my advice
is if you think you want kids have your
children young you can always be going
to college part-time while you're
raising your kids I have a friend who
did this she took like very part-time
classes it took her like 10 years but
she got her Master's in early childhood
education with no debt at all she was
able to pay as she went cuz she did it
really slowly and she was able to stay
home with her children do a little bit
of daycare work on the side and then now
her youngest is about to graduate and if
she wants to she can jump right into a
good paying job with a degree and she
has no college debt and she still got to
have her three children and raise them
at home